مع كل هزه ارتداديه جديده يشعر بها
الاتراك تهتز معها قلوب سكان هذه الاحياء
والاف من قاطني بنايات وصف عمده اسطنبول
هياكلها بالخطيره
انها مساله حياه او موت هكذا حذرت سلطات
اسطنبول سكان هنا داعيه نسحب البنايات
الهشه والقديمه الى الاسراع في فحسها وهنا
علي تركي من اصول عربيه يعيش بهذه البنايه
المتصدعه في حي الفاتح منذ سنوات في
تشققات
الفاتح وعندي هون تشققات بس فوق وانا ما
ببلغ ما في خوف في خوف بس شلون الوضع عم
بطل لبره مثلا صار شيء
بره كل ما يشغل باله هذه الايام هو كيفيه
انقاذ عائلته في حال تحركت الارض
والله يسترنا اذا كان وضع مثلا بدي يهدوا
يهدوا
مو انا بقرف على اولادك لكن شلون
غير الله سبحانه وتعالى وهالاولاد
احصت بلديه اسطنبول ما يزيد عن 100 الف
بنايه بحاجه عاجله الى فحص ضوئي واوسط
باتخاذ قرارات صارمه لانقاذ ملايين
الارواح في ظل توقعات خبراء بحدوث زلزال
هائل خلال السنوات القادمه
نحن نتوقع ان يحدث زلزال اخر قد لا يكون
مركزه في اسطنبول لكنها ستتضرر كثيرا
خصوصا واننا لم نحضر جيدا لذلك فكثير من
البنايات غير مطابقه للزلازل ويجب اعاده
النظر سريعا في معايير البناء
توقعات زادت من ارباك الناس مع تواتر
مخلفات الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب جنوب
البلاد
بالتاكيد نخاف من البنايات القديمه لو
ازيلت لكان افضل لذلك نطالب السلطات
بالتحرك قبل فوات الاوان يعني متعرضين اي
ساعه او دقيقه شيء يصير زلزال في عنا في
تركيا في اسطنبول يعني واذا صار في
اسطنبول بده يصير كارثه كبيره يعني عم
نسهر للساعه 2:00 بالليل للخوف
وامام هذا الوضع تسابق السلطات التركيه
الزمن لبحث حلول استباقيه قد تجنب البلاد
تكرار كارثه زلزال الجنوب الذي لم يتوقف
بعد عداد ضحاياه رغم تجاوزه الاربعين الف
قتيل عبد القادر خربوش العربيه اسطنبول